I'm glad we're revisiting the George
Floyd stuff because it really concerned
me the amount of drugs he had in his
system according to one Coroner's report
there are two Coroner's reports one the
family had done and they said he died I
believe it was asphyxiation that brought
on a heart attack the other one said it
was just a heart attack that killed him
and then you look at the drugs in his
system they said that he had levels of
fentanyl that were intoxicating meaning
he was high he was behind the wheel of a
car when they pulled him out he was
screaming if you see the second video of
him screaming at the cops that were
dragging him like trying to control him
to take him out of the car put him on
the ground he's like put me on the
ground put me on the ground I'm gonna
die I'm gonna he kept screaming I'm
gonna die I can't breathe I can't
breathe he was screaming before they
ever put any knees or anything on the
guy like he was struggling he was in a
bad State I think he was freaking out
because he's just been doing a speed
ball and he was behind the wheel of a
car felt like he was going to go back to
prison or go to prison